ça va attaquer au kayak
c'est une première j'allais moi en
compagnie de notre stagiaire antoine qui
est de retour et surtout avec les kayaks
prêté par haussmann calais à tabriz
merci à eux et on va voir ce qu'on
trouve tous ces ponts donc ça va être ça
nous permet d'aller bien au milieu on va
monter dans le car hier qu on va essayer
de faire plus attention que la d re fois
que cantat est monté dans un kayak parce
qu'on a les images et ça s'était pas
très bien passé
[Musique]
la ja ya une barrière
je suis là tu adores tir avec mon staff
attend tiens bon tiens tiens automne
se garer que nature
[Musique]
vas-y que
et
comme si moi je la page
et agir est de retour et c'est grâce à
rencontrer la barrière
salut
c'est ou
non on va apprendre
ah oui dans l'ombre
aujourd'hui qu'une barrière pour
l'instant bombay comment on vient de
commencer
merci
c'est un panneau ouais
mais vous vous restez là pour m'aider
ils ramènent
les gars on sent le vélo nous on leur
fils allait apporter nous ça c'est votre
mission
ah c'est pas un vélo
ces immenses et un sachet accroché
tu arrives à le prendre
il est super long
c'est bon j'ai quelque chose là
haut
c'est bizarre rires et elle tient bien
ouais vélo repéré par le président de
smile kayak à béziers
juste en dessous du pont canal
g
allez les gars allaient récupérer
merci beaucoup
vous allez vider sa
notation au les pêcheurs de trésors
c'est possible un confort là on a trouvé
un juste là ouais
il y avait rien
[Musique]
voici un truc en longueur et s'il a un
truc comme ça on mettait sa dessus aussi
c'est très loin
a dit
jacques rocher a tourné man ou un truc
là et ouais
alors tu pourras pas tu prends pas
comment faire décrocher ça ici
antoine tu me tiens pas du doigt coincé
temps
allez deuxième tentative ouais c'est
parti
il va me tenir debout
avec boite on s'est super lourd
c'est un coffre fort non
cotée
coiffant l'entraîneur de attend
quand c'est lourd ça mais aujourd'hui
c'est ça
donnait mon bateau pour pas que je
chavire
on dirait un godet de tractopelles
à
les déplacer nous
signale
croisière
13h03 c'est de toute beauté
c'est bien
ouais je sais pas ce que c'est mais
c'est vieux j'ai le cul trempé l'eau
fraîche mais il fait bon
c'est quoi
une mine
je sais pas c'est intéressant là j'ai
quelque chose
c'est lourd
c'est quoi ça
ouah
c'est énorme si vous savez que c'est un
commentaire j'attire montano et ça
devrait le faire si tu tiens voilà tout
haut
voilà bientôt ma pagaie
merci
je crois pas je crois que c'est juste
qu'on me fait très fort sur la rive à
l'avancé quand même ouais c'est plus
lourd c'est parce qu'il frotte sur les
cailloux
étonnant
je sais pas
non
un panneau c'est peut-être un panneau
c'est un panneau sûrement un sens
interdit ou quoi
tu va nous aider quentin
ayuda paul chabrol
antoine à l'aide
regardez ce champion du monde de kayak
et a fait ça toute sa vie
c'est un double panneau
c'est très beau je veux être au combat
sur notre kayak à nous je pense pas
comme ça je quand on vient de m'appeler
comme ça tu fait contrepoids aussi
antoine
[Musique]
et vous pensez que c'est quoi de votre
côté on tourne
c'est papa non à un tiroir c'est un
tiroir en dirais qui tu roules est c'est
un bon nettoyage ça
maintenant on va le sortir nous
alors y'a madison qui va nous remonter
ça j'ai pas ce que c'est mais bon
on verra
[Musique]
est ce qui nous fait qu'est-ce qui nous
fait
sympa
[Applaudissements]
sacool
machine à coudre alors c'est marrant ça
ça va bientôt
ouais sinon je vais aller sur le banc et
je sors de là haut
il est gros
gros
crois qu'on peut le mettre sur le sur
internet
on peut mettre dans le cadeau est vrai
c'est filmé le chargement hop ça va tout
va bien
je vais bien je vais aller sur le bord
samui
mon kayak
non il est comme neuf
voilà
nickel
lippi ce
troc est là derrière
abba est équipée du tout et bien
non
pas encore warin de fou
à merci
t'as vu ta vu le cross qu'on est enfin
là bas jan peter leur côté bah ouais
entier
pas aujourd'hui
bien sûr tu vas être dedans
au milieu de cet amas de dinguerie et de
bêtise
la soyeuse très bon état aux 5 centimes
de francs alors subir et 964 turin
tchèque est tout neuf ça le nickel ça
résiste très bien royal bravo pouvez
écouter cette partie de pêche touche à
touche à sa fin donc c'était plutôt
sympa ouais ça c'est pas mal de choses
n'attendait pas de jouer
du piano forest on peut importer les
années il transportait des tonnes de
bois dans leur allouer
bien aidé par les enfants du club aussi
ouais merci à tout le monde et se sont
régalés ils ont déjà envoyé des messages
en disant super après
donc un grand merci à smile au kayak à
béziers donc voilà si vous voulez faire
un tour de kayak ou une initiation aussi
pour les enfants n'hésitez pas c'est
gratuit qui vous recevra une description
l'aider avec ce mal kayak on propose
d'ailleurs on propose des ramassages de
déchets en kayak aussi l'été et après
que le club canoë kayak biterrois en
face de l'usiné à gaz à côté du skate
park toute l'année on navigue impeccable
aux plaisirs super et nous dira la
semaine prochaine pour une nouvelle
vidéo de pêche aliments testés sont
forts